what did you learn from the
mcconnell family and what did you learn
from biden's connection to china
what i learned at the white house and
this was really at the white house
because
when you before you go to the white
house you always hear these stories
about you know it's the white house
calling you know people like stand up
for like
you know how can i help you so i'm at
the white house and i'm
working with think tanks and law firms
trying to number one expose what the
chinese were doing but number two
come up with you know credible policy
options that we could implement
that would get them you know that would
prevent them from taking advantage of
our population
and time after time they say sorry i
can't help you um
i don't want to anger my chinese funders
or my chinese customers
uh my partners don't you know aren't
comfortable with us because we have a
lot of
business in china and i'm like i'm
calling from the white house
and our topic would be literally going
to give you this answer
top think tanks and the top law firms in
the country
were telling me i can't help you and so
you know i knew about i knew this
already right so it but
then when you you really get an
understanding of okay if
they won't even help the white house
then we've got a serious serious problem
what did you learn about mcconnell and
biden family
well so i put they're the only ones
that i named in the book and the reason
i did is because it's
all out in the open you can go read the
sources
the new york times report wall street
journal reports
biden his son went with him on air force
two over to china
ten days later is uh named a board
member of
bow high harvest hedge fund which is
a billion and a half dollar hedge fund
mcconnell you already talked about
his his family his father-in-law
knows zhang zaman former chairman of the
chinese communist party
and his sister-in-law is on the board
of the bank of china right what
influence
would you say is there you would they
would say
there is no influence that just happened
part of mcconnell it
happens to be my family
relationships on the part of biden he
would say that was my son
you really had nothing to do with me
although he did go over with him on on
air force two
but that being said it's not about quid
pro quo
it's about adopting xi jinping's
worldview
and his worldview which he says at davos
many times
is globalization's good you know we
should
we should continue to have open markets
we should continue to have
open systems so that we can all
collectively
do well together as a global community
that's
that's essentially i'm paraphrasing what
xi jinping says
but that's not what he believes because
if you read the chinese communist party
documents
like for instance the document number
nine that have been
that have come out of the country and
have been translated then you realize
they repudiate
every single element of for example
the atlantic charter which is a good
one-page template for the international
order signed by fdr
and winston churchill eight paragraphs
one page
democratic principles free trade rule of
law and self-determination
that's it that's that in a nutshell that
tells you about
what the un wto bretton woods all that's
about
the chinese communist party doesn't
believe in any of those
so when it's when he goes to davos xi
jinping goes to davos and he says
we need to stay open for business it's
not we need to stay
open for business because democracy
human rights civil liberty and rule of
law are great
it's because if you stay open for
business i can ensure that
we have access to science technology
innovation and capital
you